i saw you finally completed elden ring
as well dude albumin was very fun how
was that great game when you're gonna
play it
when i
when i have free time when i
have time to invest on being addicted to
something yeah yeah almond looks amazing
yeah because i i saw you playing and i'm
like god [ __ ] down it looks so fun
but it's it's really fun but like
like i don't like i know as soon as i
start elden ring it's just going to be
like when i started breath of the wild
again yeah well goodbye productivity
yeah goodbye productivity goodbye free
time because i am doing nothing but
playing this game how many hours did you
think you can do it
nearly 70 i think okay that's not too
bad my first playthrough yeah yeah it's
really really fun i i got to say it's
probably one of the best games i've
played
ever because i know people who like sank
like 200 hours instead oh yeah i still
haven't beaten it well because i mean i
like to play games on stream and i don't
i don't really want to right now i don't
want to keep playing it on stream yeah
yeah stream do a [ __ ] ton but like i
could easily you know do multiple
playthroughs and enjoy everything
i didn't i didn't even see all of it i
missed so much stuff yeah because it's
you know it's open world so there's so
much to do
um but yeah honestly really really
amazing game so many cool fights really
fun really satisfying one of the best
game designs just hands down the world
oh my god dude like the world building
in that game it's just like second to
none you've never seen a world built
like what do you mean
i've never heard you talk about world
burning before
yeah like just these giant areas that
you go to once you're like how much like
hours did they sink in building this
yeah yeah and you're there for like 10
minutes
yeah yeah there's one boss fight and
they built this whole giant thing
leading up to the boss fans like what
the [ __ ] like oh my god like just some
of the areas you're like this is so cool
and creative how the [ __ ] did you come
up with this yeah man he's building it's
insane it's insane like the whole like
i've never cared about like how a game
like world looks because it's like okay
you go into a place the boss arena you
leave no like every single aspect of
this world it's just so cool and tells
an interesting story yeah it's honestly
such a good game
one thing that's really like surprised
me about uh what i've seen people
talking about about odin ring is like
how like
how friendly it is to beginners
yeah because i feel like because it's
open world and because there are so many
options you know in previous souls games
you know you get to like a hard boss or
something or you get like this one point
and people who
were not says you know were you know
were not as pro gamer or whatever you
know like a hard skill cap yeah there
was a high skill cap where they could do
nothing
aside from you know try to beat this
boss and if they can be this boss then
you know i guess they just give up or
they just do something else but because
elder ring is open world there is just
so much more opportunity like if they
if they find a hard boss and they can
try doing something else they can grind
up a bit or you know i've heard that
there are many different builds and many
different like variations to um
to whatever what type of play style you
want to do as well and some are like
definitely easier than others oh some
are completely busted right um what's
like the busted ones then it's the blood
one there's like a bleed mechanic in the
game with certain swords that like cause
them to bleed and does percent damage
wow so percent damage on bosses you can
imagine is yeah big yeah and some swords
can apply very very quickly
so you can just chunk through bosses in
seconds with some builds right and other
builds not so much yeah like you know i
went i like messed around in the hard
area a bunch and then i went to the easy
area where i was i think i was supposed
to go yeah because you can do whatever
you want really yeah but i like
absolutely steamrolled this area like
like two shotting bosses and stuff yeah
because i was like i've gone messed
around in the really hard area that i
shouldn't have been in but you know i
that's the way i i enjoyed playing the
game it was really fun
and then it got really difficult towards
the end but that was really fun as well
because yeah i was kind of over leveled
a little bit and so it was really fun
yeah i just i had a really great time
there's not many boss fights that i
thought were bad all of the main bosses
were sick
so [ __ ] cool dude yeah such cool
bosses just a fun time really fun time
streaming as well would you say it's as
difficult as people make it out to be
again it's as difficult as you want it
to be yeah you know that you can summon
spirits and stuff so like things that
come in the fight for you and that helps
a lot it just takes aggro yeah like the
boss will stop hitting you and hit
something else so then that's like
that's more useful than them doing
damage like yeah but some of them do
damage as well like a lot right um so
yeah i mean it's it's great what like
play it it's fun it's really really fun
yeah i i i i want to find the time to do
it as i i i'll be
i want there to be i i hope there's a
game that can get game of the year over
this game because i'm i that'll be
incredible if i don't know how that
would happen if there was a game of the
year i hate being that guys i could
screw with you but like i i don't know i
don't know man have you played the new
kirby game though
i don't know i don't know what that's
pretty [ __ ] popular in my mind i
don't know what could top this this year
like a gaming experience that is
collectively agreed upon to be like an
amazing i mean i i'd be shocked i'd be
very shocked as well i'd welcome it i've
sent me some more games for me i mean i
haven't even played it in uh any other
games it's pretty better than it is
metal gear revengeance yeah
i played played it was fun that was
great i mean i i'm just i'm just so
happy that revengeance memes have come
back i played it i haven't i haven't
played it
but i feel like i've experienced
like
ninety percent of it just through memes
itself but it's so good i played it i
did it on stream and uh yeah it was
amazing what a fun game cut scenes were
as amazing armstrong is like one of my
favorite video game characters of all
time yeah like how how did how did the
japanese portray america better than
like most americans
most americans
it's just like it's so cool seeing a
game that just it just goes beyond time
like it's so impactful that it doesn't
matter how old it is i think one thing
that really impressed me with
like seeing people play metal gear
revengeance is just
like the music is just [ __ ] insane
it's not just insane but like it kind of
matches up with like the
scene or like the level that you're
playing as well it's just like the
amount of
like that that's that's what sells
revenge to me because i love anime like
fully coolly that makes it feel like
you're watching
like a music video or something as
you're watching the anime but like
vengeance feels like you're playing a
music video
as like you're going along and that's
that's the biggest selling point for me
with with revenge it's just so good yeah
it's such a fun game and yeah the
mechanics are so tight and the cutscenes
are just hilarious
because it's so overly political yeah
it's so funny
but also it's like some things he says
you're like wow
kind of a little on the nose
and then obviously all the memes that
came out of it are so good yeah if you
haven't played the game again i
recommend it how long did it take you to
complete i played it on hard and i kind
of regret it because i felt like there's
just so many very hard moments because i
wasn't very good at the game it's
because it's very fast yeah um i think
the medium is probably the best way to
enjoy the game initially and it'd be
like it'd be like five hours but it's
been like ten hours because i was like
playing hard and failing on bosses all
the [ __ ] times yeah so hard
did you like play uh play in one sitting
on stream yeah one sitting yeah okay
okay and the last fight is so worth it
because the the armstrong is just such a
fun fight it's crazy dude the bottom
meshing dude yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
one way it's just like [ __ ] standing
there
i feel like i'm part of the meme
experience now that's why i i played it
before but i've gotten halfway and i
quit because i got stuck because it's a
hard game yeah yeah yeah yeah some of
the boss fights are [ __ ] hard yeah so
yeah i mean to play on normal if you
want to chill time yeah or easy even
like you want i definitely want to play
it yeah you can do it in five hours yeah
okay so like play one stream and and two
hours is cut scenes oh brilliant that's
brilliant it's my favorite yeah it's
literally i mean it is
it's so good if you haven't played it go
and watch it you've probably watched all
the the incorrect telling of and all
that where yeah you've come from and
that i made it the [ __ ] up and yeah
making the mother of all omelets here
jack
i [ __ ] love that line this is my
favorite line
such a good game